Last resort letters aren't exactly a secret, but most of us haven't heard of them. Journalist Ron Rosenbaum came across them because he's got a Google alert that brings him any news story with the phrase "World War III" in it. He's written about nuclear war on and off for decades. And news came across the Google about a BBC documentary that details what these last resort letters are all about. Ron explained.
末日指令信并不是什么秘密，但我们大多数人都没听说过。记者罗恩·罗森鲍姆（Ron Rosenbaum）偶然发现了它们，因为他设置了谷歌快讯，只要有包含“第三次世界大战”字样的报道，他就会收到提醒。几十年来，他一直断断续续地撰写关于核战争的文章。谷歌推送了一篇英国广播公司（BBC）的纪录片报道，详细介绍了这些末日指令信的内容。罗恩对此进行了解释。
On every British nuclear submarine, there's a safe. And then within that safe is another safe, and within that safe, the inner safe, is a letter from the British prime minister. And every new prime minister that comes into office is required to handwrite this letter and seal it. And the letter instructs the submarine commander what to do when the homeland has been wiped out by a nuclear attack.
在每一艘英国核潜艇上都有一个保险箱。保险箱里还有另一个保险箱，而在那第二个保险箱，即内部保险箱里，放着一封来自英国首相的信。每一位新上任的首相都必须亲笔写下这封信并将其封存。信中指示潜艇指挥官，当祖国在核打击中被摧毁时该怎么做。
In other words, Britain's destroyed. And maybe it's better if you hear this in a British accent. This is from the BBC documentary. The letter tells the sub commander--
换句话说，英国已经被摧毁了。也许用英国口音听这段内容会更好。以下内容来自BBC的纪录片。信中告诉潜艇指挥官——
--whether to retaliate or not if Britain is already a smoking, irradiated ruin, and they're dead. It's a system peculiar to the British, and emulated by no other nuclear nations.
——如果英国已经是一片冒烟的辐射废墟，且国民已经遇难，是否要进行报复。这是一个英国特有的系统，没有其他核国家效仿。
You write, with all due respect for our British cousins, this seems, well, insane. The old-fashioned pen and ink on paper quality of it all somehow makes the system seem like it emanated from a 19th century madhouse.
你写道，出于对英国表亲的尊重，这看起来，嗯，太疯狂了。这种用笔墨在纸上书写的古老方式，不知何故让人觉得这个系统像是从19世纪的疯人院里出来的。
It's so absurd. It's Kubrick territory. It's Dr. Strangelove territory. I mean, I can't imagine, you know, someone writing, "Dear Mr. Submarine commander, I'm dead. Everyone you know is dead. We're all radioactive ashes. Here's what I'd like you to do. Number one,--"
这太荒谬了。这是库布里克风格的领域。这是《奇爱博士》的领域。我的意思是，我无法想象有人写道：“亲爱的潜艇指挥官，我死了。你认识的每个人都死了。我们都是放射性的灰烬。这是我希望你做的事。第一，……”
Rosenbaum says that the letter poses some immediate practical questions. If the whole country was just destroyed, how would the sub commander know who killed them and where to target his bomb? Does the sub commander have to show his letter to anybody else? If he's the only one reading the letter, what's to stop him from substituting his own judgement for what's on the paper?
罗森鲍姆说，这封信提出了一些直接的现实问题。如果整个国家刚刚被摧毁，潜艇指挥官怎么知道是谁杀了他们，又该向哪里投掷炸弹？潜艇指挥官必须向其他人出示这封信吗？如果他是唯一读这封信的人，又有什么能阻止他用自己的判断代替纸上写的内容呢？
And it raises a few broader questions. If the purpose of a nuclear deterrent is to convince your enemies that if they destroy you, you're going to destroy them, doesn't it undermine the whole point of having nuclear weapons in the first place to publicize the fact that there's a secret letter that very well might say no, don't retaliate?
这引发了一些更广泛的问题。如果核威慑的目的是让敌人相信，如果他们摧毁了你，你也会摧毁他们，那么公开存在一封很可能写着“不要报复”的秘密信件，难道不是从根本上破坏了拥有核武器的意义吗？
Which, Rosenbaum says, gets to the moral paradox that is at the heart of all nuclear doctrines.
罗森鲍姆说，这触及了所有核学说核心的道德悖论。
If your nation has been wiped out by a nuclear strike, is there any point in retaliating and killing tens, hundreds of millions of innocent people when the threat to retaliate has already failed?
如果你的国家已经被核打击摧毁，那么当报复的威胁已经失败时，还有必要进行报复并杀死数千万、数亿无辜平民吗？
Right. You've been annihilated.
对。你已经被彻底消灭了。
Yeah. Your nation's been annihilated. Is there any point in killing millions out of pique, vengeance, or is it justice? You know, I was at this conference of generals and admirals in July, and I actually made a point of asking them, what's the point of retaliation? And they all recognized that this was a difficult question, but they all said that well, to talk about it invites attack. Because you're undermining the threat of retaliation by even discussing your Hamlet-like doubts and dithering about whether you'd retaliate.
是的。你的国家已经被彻底消灭了。为了赌气、复仇，或者所谓的正义，去杀死数百万人还有意义吗？你知道，七月份我参加了一场将军和海军上将的会议，我专门问了他们，报复的意义何在？他们都承认这是一个难题，但他们都说，谈论这个问题只会招致攻击。因为即便只是讨论你那哈姆雷特式的疑虑和对是否报复的犹豫不决，也会削弱报复的威胁。
And so then why have a letter? Why let people know there's a handwritten letter that might say, oh, don't launch the missiles?
那为什么还要有这封信？为什么要让人们知道有一封可能写着“哦，不要发射导弹”的亲笔信？
It doesn't make any sense. Why did they make the existence of this letter known?
这没有任何意义。他们为什么要让这封信的存在为人所知？
Ron Rosenbaum contacted the British Defense Ministry and was told essentially that the letter was a fail-safe, almost a formality. If Britain were destroyed, somebody was going to need to issue an order to launch those nuclear missiles. The letter is that order.
罗恩·罗森鲍姆联系了英国国防部，得到的答复基本上是说这封信是一个故障安全装置，几乎只是一种形式。如果英国被摧毁，就需要有人下达发射那些核导弹的命令。这封信就是那道命令。
But of course, this is what they would have to say, even if it's not true, to make the threat seem credible. And you really need all the theatrics of the two safes and the personal handwritten note for all that, you know? And remember, no one knows what's in the letter. It's sealed. Or-- maybe this is something that's maybe better to hear in a British accent. As the BBC puts it--
当然，即便事实并非如此，他们也必须这么说，才能让威胁看起来可信。而且你确实需要两个保险箱和一封私人亲笔信来营造这种戏剧性，对吧？记住，没有人知道信里写了什么。它是封存的。或者——也许用英国口音听这个会更好。正如BBC所描述的那样——
History will never find out, because nobody knows what's in the prime minister's letters of last resort, and they're destroyed unread by the cabinet office when the premiership changes.
历史永远不会揭晓，因为没人知道首相的“最后手段信”里写了什么，而且在首相更换时，内阁办公室会将这些信件原封不动地销毁。
Rosenbaum believes that most people, faced with the choice of ordering genocide after the threat of genocide has failed, would not launch the missiles. And one of the few people who've had their finger on Britain's nuclear button, have ever talked about this publicly, a former defense minister named Dennis Healy, says in the BBC documentary--
罗森鲍姆认为，大多数人在面对“在种族灭绝威胁失败后下令进行种族灭绝”的选择时，都不会发射导弹。而在少数几位曾接触过英国核按钮并公开谈论过此事的英国国防部长中，丹尼斯·希利（Dennis Healy）在BBC纪录片中说——
I realize I would find it very, very difficult indeed to agree to use a nuclear weapon, and I think most people would. Because most of the people you've killed will be innocent civilians.
我意识到，要让我同意使用核武器确实非常非常困难，我想大多数人也会这么觉得。因为你杀死的绝大多数人都是无辜平民。
Which brings us back to the question, why do it this way? What's the advantage of a secret that's inside a safe, inside another safe, deep below the surface of the ocean? A secret sealed away where nobody can get to it?
这又回到了那个问题，为什么要这样做？一个锁在深海之下的保险箱里的保险箱里的秘密，到底有什么优势？一个封存起来没人能接触到的秘密？
Well, Rosenbaum found himself asking a very similar question while researching a very different subject years ago. He spent ten years writing a book about Adolf Hitler. And he said that when he was researching that, some of the evidence that he's heard about-- there was stories, for example, of a hypnotherapist report on Adolf Hitler from when Adolf Hitler was in a sanitarium after the first World War-- that supposedly explained why Hitler wanted to conquer the world. And this was, supposedly, again, sealed away in a safe deposit box in Switzerland.
嗯，罗森鲍姆多年前在研究一个完全不同的主题时，也问过类似的问题。他花了十年时间写了一本关于阿道夫·希特勒的书。他说，当他研究那个课题时，听到了一些证据——例如，有传言称一战后阿道夫·希特勒在疗养院时的一份催眠治疗报告，据称解释了希特勒为何想要征服世界。而这份报告，据称也被锁在瑞士的一个保险箱里。
And Rosenbaum has a theory about the appeal of that kind of thing.
罗森鲍姆对这类事情的吸引力有自己的理论。
It allows us to believe that certain truths do exist. There's an explanation for Hitler, but it's locked away in some safe deposit box beyond our grasp. So it gives us a feeling that this is not some numinous, irretrievable mystery. We could explain Hitler, if only we had found the right safe deposit box.
它让我们相信某些真相是确实存在的。关于希特勒有一个解释，只是它被锁在我们够不着的某个保险箱里。所以这给我们一种感觉，这并不是什么神秘莫测、无法追回的谜题。如果我们能找到那个正确的保险箱，我们就能解释希特勒。
To follow your logic, then the advantage of having this letter with the order locked away in a box inside another box-- what it does is that you don't want your enemy to know that you're not going to launch those missiles, but you don't want to think for yourself that you are. So it lets you believe both things. It lets two truths exist at the same time.
照你的逻辑，那么把带有指令的信锁在盒中之盒里的好处是——你不想让敌人知道你不会发射那些导弹，但你也不想让自己认为你会发射。所以这让你能同时相信这两件事。这让两种真相同时存在。
Yes, I suppose that's true. It allows us to have it both ways.
是的，我想是这样。它让我们能够鱼与熊掌兼得。
From WEBZ Chicago, it's This American Life, distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass.
这里是芝加哥WBEZ电台的《美国生活》（This American Life），由国际公共广播电台（PRI）发行。我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。
Today on our show, Contents Unknown. Stories of truths, big and small, that are locked away. Sometimes the most exciting thing about these truths is knowing that they're out there, the answer exists, but you don't know it.
今天我们节目的主题是“内容未知”。讲述那些被锁起来的大大小小的真相。有时候，关于这些真相最令人兴奋的事情就是知道它们存在，答案就在那里，只是你不知道而已。
Our show today in three acts. Act one is about the truths contained in America's mini storage lockers. No kidding. Act two is about the truth of an entire empire 1,400 years ago. Act three is about truth wiped away from inside someone's head. Stay with us.
今天的节目分为三幕。第一幕关于美国迷你储物柜里隐藏的真相。没开玩笑。第二幕关于1400年前一个帝国的真相。第三幕关于被从某人脑海中抹去的真相。请继续收听。
Act one. Needle in a crap sack. Self storage units. There's a lot of them. 2.35 billion with a B square feet in the United States, according to the Self Storage Association. That, in case you're wondering, is 7.4 square feet of self storage for every man, woman, and child in this country, meaning all of us, all of us, could stand inside self storage at the same time.
第一幕。干草堆里的针。自助存储单元。数量非常多。根据自助存储协会的数据，美国有23.5亿平方英尺。如果你好奇的话，这意味着这个国家平均每个人、每位女性和每个孩子分摊到7.4平方英尺的自助存储空间，也就是说，我们所有人，所有人，都可以同时站在自助存储设施里。
And when people do not pay their self storage bills after the facility tries to collect through all the normal means and fails, often the contents of the storage lockers get auctioned off.
当人们在设施通过所有正常渠道催收仍未缴清租金时，储物柜里的物品通常会被拍卖。
Jon Mooallem went to some of those auctions in Northern California. They're a big exercise in guessing at the unknown.
乔恩·穆阿勒姆（Jon Mooallem）去了北加州的一些拍卖会。这是一场针对未知的猜谜游戏。
This morning, a little after nine, a crowd of a few dozen prospectors is already waiting in the fog outside Bridgehead Self Storage, an hour east of San Francisco. The auctioneer, a guy with the briskly mustache named John Cardoza, runs a company called Storage Auction Experts. Today he'll go to six different storage places in three different towns and auction off upwards of 50 units. The crowd will follow him for nine hours.
今天早上九点刚过，几十名寻宝者已经在旧金山东部一小时车程处的“桥头自助存储”（Bridgehead Self Storage）外的浓雾中等待了。拍卖师是一个留着整洁胡须的人，名叫约翰·卡多扎（John Cardoza），经营着一家名为“存储拍卖专家”的公司。今天他将前往三个不同城镇的六个不同的存储点，拍卖超过50个单元。人群将跟随他九个小时。
Hey Ricky? Go ahead and open up this one too, please. We've got two of them open.
嘿，里奇？请把这个也打开。我们已经开了两个了。
Here's how it works. A unit's door is rolled open. No one's allowed to step inside or open any boxes or touch anything at all. The mob just stands there, sweeping their flashlights around, making educated guesses about what's inside. They crane their necks, contort their bodies, or step up on little folding stools they brought for a better look into the nooks and corners. "You gotta get all up in there, like a proctologist," one guy explains.
运作方式是这样的。单元的门被卷起。任何人都不允许踏入、打开任何盒子或触摸任何东西。人群只是站在那里，用手电筒四处扫射，对里面的东西做出有根据的猜测。他们伸长脖子，扭动身体，或者踏上他们带来的小折叠凳，以便更好地观察角落。正如一个人解释的那样：“你得像个直肠科医生一样深入探究。”
I spoke to a giddy-looking woman in the crowd about what she saw.
我和人群中一位看起来兴高采烈的女士谈了谈她看到了什么。
There is an unusual-shaped box that is behind these old mattresses that are leaned up, and the mattresses did not lean all the way up against the wall. So I kind of was really trying to look behind there and see. So that's what drew my attention to it, right there. So hopefully it is what I'm thinking it might be.
在那些靠着的旧床垫后面有一个形状不寻常的盒子，而且床垫没有完全靠墙。所以我真的很想透过那里看个究竟。就是那个吸引了我的注意。希望它真的是我所想的那样。
What are you thinking it might be?
你觉得那是什么？
I don't know yet, but I have something in my head, yeah.
我还不知道，但我脑子里有个想法。
I couldn't get her to even say it out loud. She didn't want to jinx it.
我甚至无法让她说出来。她不想破坏好运。
Locker number A80, the one out here. The one out here. Here we go, ladies and gentlemen. How many dollars? Can I get $50 start it?
A80号柜，外面的那个。外面的这个。开始了，女士们先生们。多少钱？50美元起拍好吗？
It's informal. The auctioneer stands right in front of the open locker. People raise their hands to bid. Most of them are regulars. They all know each other and are here to make a modest second income. They resell what they buy on eBay or at flea markets.
这是非正式的。拍卖师站在打开的柜子前。人们举手竞拍。他们大多是常客。他们彼此认识，来这里是为了赚取一份微薄的额外收入。他们转售买到的东西，在eBay或跳蚤市场上卖掉。
They have their niches. One guy does antiques. Several are into tools. One loves anything military.
他们有各自的专长。一个人做古董。几个人喜欢工具。一个人什么军用物品都喜欢。
But they all know the stories of blockbuster hauls, too. The hippies who, for $225, bought the unit of a Sacramento rail yard heir several years ago and found a stockpile of silver coins inside.
但他们也都听说过大获全胜的故事。几年前，几个嬉皮士用225美元买下了一个萨克拉门托铁路大亨的单元，发现里面藏着一批银币。
In 2007, a guy in Southern California bought Paris Hilton's storage locker when she fell $200 behind on the rent. He resold it to another guy who set up a website called Paris Exposed and charged $39.97 for a virtual tour of the contents. There were topless photos in there, ones people hadn't seen yet.
2007年，南加州一个人买下了帕里斯·希尔顿（Paris Hilton）因欠租200美元而被拍卖的储物柜。他转手卖给另一个人，那人建立了一个名为“帕里斯揭秘”（Paris Exposed）的网站，并收取39.97美元的费用进行虚拟参观。里面有没人看过的上空照。
A more common scenario, though, goes like this. You spend several hundred dollars on what turns out to be cheap halogen lamps, cassette singles by Heavy D & the Boyz, and a couple of bent mattresses. Then you've got to spend the rest of your day shoveling all that crap to the dump, which charges you more money to throw it out.
不过，更常见的情况是这样：你花了数百美元买了些廉价卤素灯、Heavy D & the Boyz的盒式单曲和几张弯曲的床垫。然后你得花掉剩下的一整天把这些垃圾运到垃圾填埋场，还得额外支付弃置费。
People think you find, like, diamond rings and stuff, and everybody's doing this for a decade.
人们认为你会找到钻戒之类的东西，虽然每个人都干了十年了。
That's Christine. She's here with her friend Lois. They say for every good score, there are plenty of disappointments.
那是克里斯汀。她和她的朋友路易丝在这里。她们说，每一次好的收获背后，都有很多失望。
All you find is other people's porno, stuff that goes along with that, nasty clothes that smell like mildew, dead rats.
你只能找到别人的色情杂志、类似的杂物、闻起来像霉味的脏衣服、死老鼠。
Oh, definitely dead rats.
哦，绝对有死老鼠。
And you know how long it's been there, and [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
而且你知道它在那里待了多久了……
With such a great likelihood of failure, you have to give yourself an edge. And everybody's got their own arsenal of tricks.
面对如此高的失败概率，你必须给自己创造优势。每个人都有自己的技巧储备。
What do you look for when the door opens?
门打开时你找什么？
Cobwebs. Seriously, cobwebs. That stuff hasn't been moved in a long time, so you know no one's gone through it.
蛛网。说真的，蛛网。那些东西很久没动过了，所以你知道没人翻过它。
Cobwebs tell you the renters didn't have a chance to whisk away their valuables before the manager locked them out.
蛛网告诉你，租户在经理锁定他们之前没机会拿走贵重物品。
When it looks like a unit's been churned over, you see upside down furniture, boxes crushed on boxes. It just indicates either low quality, or they took what they wanted out of there before they knew they were losing it. So you're not going to get anything.
当一个单元看起来被翻过时，你会看到倒扣的家具，盒子上压着盒子。这只说明要么质量低劣，要么他们在知道要失去单元前拿走了他们想要的。所以你什么也得不到。
That's Dave Lewis, a stick-thin guy with a beard. He's wearing a denim work jacket that's way too big for him. He looks like a precocious kid in a smock. Dave's been going to auctions off and on for most of his life.
那是戴夫·刘易斯（Dave Lewis），一个瘦削、留着胡子的家伙。他穿着一件对他来说太大的牛仔工作夹克。他看起来像个穿着罩衫的早熟孩子。戴夫大半辈子都在断断续续地参加拍卖会。
But you know, you see a unit that's neatly stacked and organized, thought went into it, certain brand names or a tendency for a lot of the items in there to be brand or quality items versus, say, just generics or that kind of thing-- so people tend to print really nicely, and just the level of organization goes into some of them lets you know, hey. Somebody took the time as value here.
但是你知道，你看到一个整齐堆放和组织的单元，投入了心思，有特定的品牌名称，或者里面很多物品倾向于品牌或高质量的，而不是说仅仅是普通产品——人们往往印刷得很好，仅仅是组织水平就能让你知道，嘿，有人花了时间，这里有价值。
And the kinds of boxes matter, too. Crisp, brand new moving boxes, good. Rat-bitten old diaper boxes, not good. A plasma TV box is almost guaranteed not to have a plasma TV in it, but it tells you something about the income bracket you're dealing with.
盒子的种类也很重要。崭新的搬家盒，好。被老鼠咬过的旧尿布盒，不好。等离子电视盒里几乎肯定没有等离子电视，但它能告诉你你面对的是什么收入阶层。
No unit's a sure thing, Lois tells me. Every once in a while, one breaks your heart.
没有哪个单元是百分之百稳赚的，路易丝告诉我。每隔一段时间，就会有一个让你心碎。
I know one guy, a story I heard a few years ago. This guy-- they opened a huge unit, and it was all boxes packed neatly, and they all said "Fragile Crystal" on the side. He bid up to $500 or $600 or something on that. And when he emptied it, it was all just a bunch of garbage that belonged to someone named Crystal.
我认识一个人，几年前听过一个故事。这人——他们打开了一个巨大的单元，里面全是整齐堆放的盒子，侧面都写着“易碎水晶”。他竞拍到了500或600美元左右。等他清空后，发现里面全是属于一个叫克里斯塔尔（Crystal）的人的一堆垃圾。
I haven't seen him for a while either, come to think of it.
仔细想想，我也有一阵子没见到他了。
Still, the game is the same for everyone. You're trying to analyze what you can see to get a sense of what you can't. Dave makes it sound a little mystical, even. As soon as the door opens, he starts building a profile of the renter in his head, really trying to get to know the person.
不过，游戏对每个人来说都是一样的。你试图分析你能看到的东西，来感知你看不到的东西。戴夫让它听起来甚至有点神秘。门一打开，他就开始在脑海中勾勒租户的轮廓，真正试图去了解那个人。
This looks to me like somebody who did in-home daycare. Beanbags, a number of individual tubs that have crayons, chalk-- you know, not enough for one kid, about enough for 20. So it probably, in my estimation, this should not go anywhere over a hundred.
这看起来像是做家庭日托的人。懒人包，很多装有蜡笔、粉笔的独立桶——你知道，这可不是一个孩子用的，大约是20个孩子的量。所以在我看来，这不应该超过一百美元。
Although there is some Star Wars sheets right there, so you might have the fanatic collector who notices that or something. You never know.
虽然那里有一些《星球大战》的床单，所以你可能会遇到注意到这一点或什么的狂热收藏家。你永远不知道。
You can see if a lot of people are interested in it, see how long it's taking them to look. They're trying to find something to draw themselves into buying it. Something to say, buy me.
你可以看到是否有很多人对它感兴趣，看看他们花了多长时间看。他们试图找到一些东西来吸引自己去买。一些说“买我”的东西。
That's Mike DeHaas. He's not like Dave at all. He's not like anyone else here. Mike doesn't fantasize or make projections about what can't be seen. The stacks of anonymous boxes, the big, enticing furniture shapes draped over with blankets. To some bidders, these just mean more chances to win.
那是迈克·德哈斯（Mike DeHaas）。他一点也不像戴夫。他不像是这里的任何人。迈克不会对看不到的东西进行幻想或投射。那些成堆的匿名盒子，那些被毯子覆盖的巨大的、诱人的家具形状。对一些竞标者来说，这些意味着更多的获胜机会。
To Mike, they're traps, a mirage. His strategy is the anti-strategy. He just bids on what's visible. When the door rolls up, Mike quickly tallies up the value of everything he can see and definitively identify in the unit, and then bids based on that and only that.
对迈克来说，它们是陷阱，是海市蜃楼。他的策略是反策略。他只竞拍可见的东西。当门卷起时，迈克会迅速计算他能看到并确定标识出的所有东西的价值，然后仅以此为基础进行竞拍。
It could be a piece of art, it could be a coin, it could be a baseball card, it could be a toy, it could be an old military item, it could be a piece of clothing. You just never know. So I look at everything realistically. I've just had a rough life and I've been through a lot of things that most people shouldn't, so I don't see things like, you know, I see it for what it is. Two plus two is four. That's how I describe everything, and that's how I see it. So I don't do this with a lot of hope. I do it realistically.
它可能是艺术品、硬币、棒球卡、玩具、旧军事物品、衣服。你永远不知道。所以我以现实的态度看一切。我生活过得很艰难，经历过很多大多数人不应该经历的事情，所以我不像那样看待事物，我看到它的本质。二加二等于四。这就是我描述一切的方式，也是我看待一切的方式。所以我带着很多希望做这件事。我现实地做这件事。
Mike's buying at auctions and reselling at flea markets around the state full time, just barely supporting his girlfriend and two little kids. I keep noticing Mike far away from the rest of the crowd, staring at the ground with his hood pulled over his head and a Maglite flung through his belt.
迈克全职在拍卖会上买东西并在州内的跳蚤市场上转售，勉强维持女朋友和两个小孩的生活。我一直注意到迈克远离人群，兜帽拉过头顶，腰间挂着Maglite手电筒，盯着地面看。
Mike's got a history with these storage places. He tells me his parents did a lot of drugs his whole childhood.
迈克在这些存储点有段历史。他告诉我他父母整个童年都在吸毒。
And he got to the point where we ended up homeless and put everything into a storage unit. And instead of trying to save our storage unit, they spent all the money they had on more drugs, and kept repeating that process, so we lost our unit. I've had a whole 10 by 30 just gone one day. My whole life up until the age of 15. Everything before my parents lost because of their drug habit. So it was rather disappointing and things like that.
到了我们最终无家可归的地步，把所有东西都放进了存储单元。他们不仅没试图拯救我们的单元，反而把所有的钱都花在买毒品上，并且不断重复这个过程，所以我们失去了单元。我曾经有整个10乘30的单元，一天之内就没了。我15岁之前的一生。我父母因为毒瘾失去了一切。所以这相当令人失望之类的。
And that's why what I try to do is make sure like anything personal, especially baby photos, baby books, things of that nature, I try to put it all in a box and give it back to the office, and they will return it to the people. Because it makes me feel a little better.
这就是为什么我试图确保任何私人物品，特别是婴儿照片、婴儿书之类的东西，我试着把它们都放进盒子里交给办公室，他们会把它们还给人们。因为这让我感觉好一点。
We got to get to the next one because there's bad parking.
我们得去下一个地方，因为那里停车很难。
Where is this?
这是哪里？
On San Miguel.
在圣米格尔（San Miguel）。
When we reach the sixth and final storage facility of the day, San Miguel Mini Storage, a short, barrel-chested Asian guy shows up, turning heads. Darren, someone whispers.
当我们到达当天的第六个也是最后一个存储设施——圣米格尔迷你存储时，一个矮壮的亚洲家伙出现了，引人侧目。有人低语：“达伦（Darren）来了。”
Well, I came back here because I scored last time, so I'm going to come back again, see if I can score again.
嗯，我回来是因为上次我大赚了一笔，所以我要再来一次，看看能不能再赚一笔。
Last time Darren came to an auction at this place, he found a big box of jewelry buried in the back of a unit. He made 40 grand from it, or 400 grand, maybe. The number changes as the story gets told and retold and passes into legend.
上次达伦来这里的拍卖会时，他在单元后面发现了一大盒珠宝。他赚了4万，或者40万，也许吧。随着故事被讲述、重述并成为传说，数字也在变。
This helps explain why, when we get here, the crowd's suddenly tripled in size. There's close to 100 people here now, because word's gotten around that San Miguel Mini Storage is the kind of place where Darrens happen.
这有助于解释为什么当我们到达时，人群突然增加了三倍。现在这里有近100人，因为消息传开了，圣米格尔迷你存储是那种会发生“达伦奇迹”的地方。
But not today. There were 27 units to auction here, and one after the other, the doors went up, and none looked even remotely like a Darren-maker.
但今天没有。这里有27个单元要拍卖，门一扇接一扇地打开，没有一个看起来像能产生“达伦”的地方。
[? Last chance today. Here we go now, locker--
[？]今天最后的机会。开始了，柜子——
To be honest, the afternoon has blurred together in a model of obsolete computer monitors, dusty sweatpants, vacuums, and bingo cards. I remember seeing a black bedazzled sombrero somewhere, the kind that Three Amigos wore. I remember a big box of snack food-- "Chicken Ranch Flavor-Blasted Goldfish," they were called. Those are starting to feel like really fun memories now.
老实说，整个下午在废旧电脑显示器、满是灰尘的运动裤、吸尘器和宾果卡中变得模糊不清。我记得在某处看到了一顶镶满水钻的黑色宽边帽，那是《三个阿米戈》（Three Amigos）戴的那种。我记得一大盒零食——它们被称为“鸡肉牧场风味爆发金鱼饼干”。那些开始感觉像是非常有趣的记忆了。
The sun's set. The temperature's dropped. The hardcore veterans are all feeling crappy and disappointed. And then--
太阳下山了。温度下降了。老手们都感到又累又失望。然后——
Oh, [BLEEP] [BLEEP]
哦，[哔] [哔]。
This last unit, a 10 by 25, is a cartoonish mound of junk. It's such a jumbled, ridiculous end of the long day that all the jaded old-timers have perked up. They're almost enjoying it.
这最后一个单元，10乘25英尺，是一堆卡通式的垃圾。这是一天结束时如此杂乱、荒谬的结局，以至于所有厌倦的老手们都振作了起来。他们几乎在享受它。
Oh my God. Shopping carts?
哦天哪。购物车？
Was this a family?
这是一家人吗？
Is that a shrunken head right there?
那是一个缩小的头颅吗？
Wow, what's in the back?
哇，后面是什么？
I ask Mike if he sees anything here worth bidding on. Everyone's just baffled.
我问迈克他是否看到值得竞拍的东西。大家都困惑不已。
Oh, there's nothing to describe here. I don't even know what to use as a word. An abomination.
哦，这里没什么可描述的。我甚至不知道用什么词来形容。这是一个畸形。
It's like a wall, right? It's like a wall of stuff with something behind it.
就像一堵墙，对吧？就像一堵东西的墙，后面有东西。
It's a wall of-- somebody was really desperate, and in a big hurry to unload wherever, their garage, their house, whatever, they shoved it all in.
这是一堵——有人非常绝望，非常匆忙地清空车库、房子或任何地方，把所有东西都塞了进去。
And when they opened the door, stuff just spilled out of the bottom.  A bunch of books and a camping chair. There's a pizza stone. There's books about U-boats, boxes. It looks as though someone had a bulldozer inside the unit and just pushed everything all the way to the front. And behind there, people are saying they see a giant Santa Claus.
当他们打开门时，东西从底部溢出来了。一堆书和一个露营椅。有一个披萨石。有关于U艇的书、盒子。看起来像是有人在单元里开了推土机，把所有东西都推到了前面。而在后面，人们说他们看到了一个巨大的圣诞老人。
Someone shouts out the name of a bar to head to. A man tells his girlfriend, "Go use the bathroom. Let's get out of here."
有人喊出了一个酒吧的名字准备去喝一杯。一个男人告诉他的女朋友，“去用下洗手间。我们走吧。”
The auctioneer starts the bidding. Some people are actually raising their hands.
拍卖师开始了竞拍。有些人真的举起了手。
Now 325 now 350 new blood now 375. Now 400.
现在325，现在350，新买家，现在375。现在400。
It gets competitive.
竞争变得激烈。
Now 425. 400, 425, now 450. Anybody else? 450? Sold them out. 425.
现在425。400，425，现在450。还有别人吗？450？成交。425。
The winner turns out to be Dave and his girlfriend Linda for $425 plus fees. They own his giant pile of tetanus now. And the weird thing is, they're thrilled.
获胜者是戴夫和他的女朋友琳达，价格425美元加上费用。他们现在拥有这堆巨大的破伤风源了。奇怪的是，他们很兴奋。
Behind this could be anything.
这后面可能什么都有。
Wait, wait, wait. We have to get a full explanation on this. Because you understand that this was very controversial unit. So you knew right away you wanted this one?
等等，等等，等等。我们必须对此有一个完整的解释。因为你知道这是一个非常有争议的单元。所以你一眼就知道你想要这个？
I did, as soon as I knew that there was a hollow spot behind there. That could be-- could be nothing. They could have been just idiots. And Dave says they took the good stuff out. But who's going to pay $225 on a unit every month to store this? There could be motorcycles, jet skis, a car. Could be anything. It could be nothing. We could've just flushed $485 down the toilet. So we'll see.
是的，当我发现后面有一个空隙时我就知道了。那可能是——可能什么也没有。他们可能只是白痴。戴夫说他们拿走了好东西。但是谁会每个月花225美元租一个单元来存这些东西？可能有摩托车、喷气滑雪板、汽车。什么都可能有。也可能什么都没有。我们可能刚刚把485美元冲进了马桶。所以，我们等着瞧。
You want to just climb over the--
你想要爬过去——
I do, I do. But I don't have a flashlight.
我想要，我想要。但我没有手电筒。
I think I can--
我想我可以——
Dave clambers up, sidestepping a not totally empty jar of Red Raspberry Smuckers and an electric carving knife.
戴夫爬了上去，绕过一个还没完全空的Red Raspberry Smuckers果酱瓶和一个电动雕刻刀。
Holy moly.
我的天啊。
What is it?
是什么？
Uh-- OK, I don't-- there's nothing like a motorcycle, or-- but for everyone that thought the back half of this unit was empty, they were absolutely dead wrong. This thing is about four feet deep and going all the way about 15 feet back. In fact, I see three more shopping carts, books, boxes, bags, a seven foot tall Santa-- oh, I'm telling you. There's no telling here. This is one huge heap.
嗯——好的，我不——没有什么像摩托车那样的——但对于那些认为这个单元后半部分是空的的人来说，他们大错特错了。这个东西大约有四英尺深，向后延伸了约15英尺。事实上，我看到了另外三个购物车、书、盒子、袋子、一个七英尺高的圣诞老人——哦，我告诉你。这里说不准。这是一大堆东西。
No motorcycle? Boo!
没有摩托车？太扫兴了！
If he feels defeated, though, he's trying not to let on. He and Linda start freeing things from the mass, including bags of recyclable bottles. And Dave especially is trying to put a good spin on whatever they find.
不过，如果他感到挫败，他尽量不表现出来。他和琳达开始从这堆垃圾中清理出东西，包括成袋的可回收瓶子。戴夫特别试图为他们发现的任何东西找点好处。
Yeah, this is, I don't think it's any kind of a special wine. It looks like Charles Shaw Cabernet Sauvignon 2001. OK, see, we found two bottles of one unopened wine, a 2001 Cabernet Sauvignon, a 2005 something else. So we may have somebody's wine collection in here, too. See now, this is the kind of stuff I like to see. This offset seeing those recyclables.
是的，我不认为这是什么特别的酒。看起来像是2001年的查尔斯·肖赤霞珠（Charles Shaw Cabernet Sauvignon）。好吧，你看，我们发现了两瓶未开封的酒，一瓶2001年的赤霞珠，一瓶2005年的其他酒。所以我们也可能有某人的藏酒在里面。看，这就是我喜欢看到的东西。这抵消了看到那些可回收物的感觉。
Gradually, though, the bad omens stack up.
然而，坏兆头逐渐堆积起来。
I almost hate to comment on this, but I know what it is. Methamphetamine. Not the actual stuff, but this is what people do when they're on meth.
我几乎不想评论这个，但我知道这是什么。甲基苯丙胺（冰毒）。不是真正的毒品，而是人们在吸食冰毒时会做的东西。
Can you describe what it is?
你能描述一下它是什么吗？
I guess somebody thought they would improve on the wheel. Yeah, it's a bicycle that somebody thought that they could try to take coat hangers and make a bunch of spokes out of, and then wrap it around the tire, it looks like to try to keep the tire on the rim.
我想有人觉得他们可以改进自行车轮。是的，这是一辆有人试图用衣架做成一堆辐条，然后把它缠在轮胎上，看起来像是试图把轮胎固定在轮辋上的自行车。
And I just, somebody's got to be on drugs to do this. I've seen it way too many times. You come across something like this where you see somebody's done something to it that absolutely makes no sense. I mean, they've basically made the bike unrideable doing what they tried to do to it. So I would be willing to bet that this person had a drug problem.
我只是觉得，有人一定是吸毒了才会这样做。我见过太多次了。你会遇到这样的事情，看到某人对它做了完全没意义的事。我的意思是，他们基本让这辆车没法骑了。所以我敢打赌，这个人有毒瘾。
And that's how I leave them, scrabbling through the unit in a floodlight in the cold. Maybe they lost. Maybe it was a draw. Dave says it'll take a week to sort everything out.
我就在那儿看着他们，在寒冷的灯光下翻找着那个单元。也许他们输了。也许是平局。戴夫说要花一周时间才能整理好一切。
Jon Mooallem is a contributing writer for New York Times Magazine.
乔恩·穆阿勒姆是《纽约时报杂志》的特约撰稿人。
Coming up-- when you lose your memory in India and you're searching for whatever clues you can find to reconstruct who you are. What's the protocol they use to help you?  And yes, incredibly, this happens enough that there is an informal protocol of sorts, in some places. That's in the second half of our show from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International when our program continues.
接下来——当你在印度失去记忆，正在寻找任何可以找到的线索来重构你是谁时。他们使用什么协议来帮助你？是的，令人难以置信的是，这种情况发生得足够多，以至于在某些地方有一种非正式的协议。请继续收听我们下半部分的节目，来自芝加哥公共广播电台和国际公共广播电台。
This American Life from Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme, bring you different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's program-- Contents Unknown. Stories of people having to guess at the mystery of what is inside all sorts of various things. We've arrived at act two of our show.
艾拉·格拉斯的《美国生活》。每周我们都会选择一个主题，为您带来关于该主题的各种故事。今天的节目——“内容未知”。讲述人们不得不猜测各种事物内部奥秘的故事。我们来到了节目的第二幕。
Act Two. He Shapes Ship Shapes By the Seashore.
第二幕。他在海边塑造船舶模型。
All right. I'm going to say two words to you now. Byzantine Empire. Quick! When? Who? Where? What?
好了。现在我要对你说两个词。拜占庭帝国。快！什么时候？谁？哪里？什么？
Yeah, me neither. But I look it up. The Byzantine Empire is basically the eastern half of the Roman Empire, which broke off. It existed from around 300 AD to the 1400s.
是的，我也一样。但我查了一下。拜占庭帝国基本上是分裂出去的罗马帝国的东半部分。它存在于公元300年左右到1400年代。
And archaeologists thought they knew most of the big things that you'd want to know about the Byzantine Empire decades ago. So much so that by the 1950s, they'd bulldozed Byzantine sites to get at stuff that seemed more interesting underneath it, Greek and Roman stuff.
考古学家几十年前以为他们已经知道了关于拜占庭帝国你想知道的大部分大事。以至于到了1950年代，他们推平了拜占庭遗址，为了去发掘下面看起来更有趣的东西，希腊和罗马的东西。
And then everything changed. Our whole understanding of the Byzantines changed. And the way we got to this new understanding starts with one shipwreck. Adam Davidson tells what happened.
然后一切都变了。我们对拜占庭人的整个理解改变了。而我们获得这种新理解的方式始于一次沉船事故。亚当·戴维森（Adam Davidson）讲述了发生的事情。
Fred van Doorninck does not do anything on a lark. Except one thing, once.
弗雷德·范·多尼克（Fred van Doorninck）做事从不突发奇想。除了那一次。
In 1961, when he was in archaeology grad school, he took a break and went to Turkey, put on some scuba gear, and checked out a 1,400 year old shipwreck off the coast of the tiny island of Yassiada.
1961年，当他还是考古学研究生时，他休息了一会儿去了土耳其，穿上水肺潜水装备，查看了亚西岛（Yassiada）小岛海边的一艘1400年前的沉船。
At the very beginning, I just thought this was a summer of adventure. But slowly-- well, not too slowly. I think by the second year, I was hooked.
起初，我只觉得这是一个冒险的夏天。但慢慢地——嗯，没那么慢。我想到了第二年，我就上瘾了。
Hooked on Yassiada?
对亚西岛上瘾？
Yes. Because this ship was a great mystery, you know? It needed to be put back together, and it all needed to be explained.
是的。因为这艘船是一个巨大的谜题，你知道吗？它需要被拼凑起来，而且这一切都需要得到解释。
It was surprising that Fred, of all people, took this on, since Fred, by his on admission, is not a water guy.
令人惊讶的是弗雷德，竟然会承担这项工作，因为弗雷德自己承认，他不是一个水上人。
I have a throat that when one little drop of liquid hits it, it closes. And I never enjoyed diving one minute.
我的喉咙一旦碰到一滴液体，它就会闭合。我从来没有享受过一分钟的潜水。
Fred used to come up from almost every dive with blood in his mask.
弗雷德几乎每次潜水上来时面罩里都带着血。
That's George Bass, Fred's research partner in what would become a 50 year exploration of this one Byzantine ship. Speaking of the Byzantines, George remembers a grad school trip to Greece this way.
那是乔治·巴斯（George Bass），弗雷德在对这艘拜占庭船只进行的为期50年的探索中的研究伙伴。提到拜占庭人，乔治记得一次研究生去希腊的旅行是这样的。
I didn't even get out of the bus at Byzantine churches. I just found them so boring. I found everything about the Byzantine period just awful.
我甚至没有下过车看那些拜占庭教堂。我发现它们太无聊了。我发现关于拜占庭时期的所有东西都很糟糕。
So a guy who hates diving meets a guy bored by the Byzantine Empire. Naturally, an academic buddy movie ensues in which two men find that the path to happiness lies in diving and studying the Byzantines.
所以一个讨厌潜水的人遇到一个对拜占庭帝国感到无聊的人。自然地，一部学术伙伴电影上演了，两个男人发现快乐的道路在于潜水和研究拜占庭人。
And along the way, they create an entire new field-- underwater archaeology. Because they were the first archaeologists to thoroughly excavate a ship on the seafloor. George remembers diving and seeing Yassiada for the first time.
在此过程中，他们开创了一个全新的领域——水下考古学。因为他们是第一批彻底发掘海床上船只的考古学家。乔治记得第一次潜水看到亚西岛时的情景。
It was a mound of jars, amphoras, two-handle jars, we call them amphoras, and it stood maybe three feet high, something like that.
那是一堆罐子，双耳瓶，我们称之为双耳瓶，它大约有三英尺高，类似那样。
So there's no ship, there's no--?
所以没有船，没有——？
No ship. In the Mediterranean, in fact, most of the oceans of the world are filled with shipworms, or marine borers, mollusks that eat wood.
没有船。在地中海，事实上，世界上的大部分海洋都充满了船蛆，或者海洋钻孔动物，吃木头的软体动物。
Like water termites?
像水白蚁一样？
Like water termites, exactly.
就像水白蚁，完全正确。
You guys must hate those water termites more than anything in the world.
你们一定比世界上任何东西都更讨厌那些水白蚁。
Oh, yes, very. We yet only the part of the ship that's sunk down into the sand. So we're always hoping that a ship that we excavate has fallen onto one side, that we will learn more about it.
哦，是的，非常。我们只发掘出沉入沙子里的那部分船体。所以我们总是希望我们发掘的船只是一侧着地，这样我们就能了解更多。
Ships are symmetrical. You find one side safely buried in the sand, you know what the other side looks like.
船只都是对称的。你找到一侧安全埋在沙子里，你就知道另一侧长什么样了。
Now remember, these are the first diving archaeologists. Scuba had only been invented in the 1940s. It was so new they could only stay on the seafloor for 20 minutes at a time. Imagine trying to excavate some ancient pyramid or something, and you can only go there and work for 20 minutes, and then you have to leave.
现在记住，这些是第一批潜水考古学家。水肺潜水直到1940年代才被发明。它太新了，他们每次只能在海床上停留20分钟。想象一下试图发掘某个古金字塔之类的东西，你只能去那里工作20分钟，然后就得离开。
And in those 20 minutes, George and Fred had to solve problems nobody ever faced before.
在那20分钟里，乔治和弗雷德必须解决没人面对过的问题。
An ancient hole on the seabed, the wood is very fragmentary. And so if you sweep with your hand to get the sand away, a little piece of wood, not bigger than two playing cards put together, for example, that's just going to float away. So we had to figure out some way to keep it all intact while we mapped it.
海床上的一个古老洞穴，木头非常破碎。所以如果你用手扫去沙子，一块不超过两张扑克牌拼在一起那么大的小木片，就会飘走。所以我们必须想办法在测绘时保持它完好无损。
I thought of knitting needles. I couldn't find any. A Turkish colleague suggested bicycle spokes. We ended up buying more than a thousand bicycle spokes, sharpening one end of each one, turning with the other end over so we could pin to the seabed every little fragment of wood we found.
我想到织毛衣针。我没找到。一位土耳其同事建议用自行车辐条。最后我们买了超过一千根自行车辐条，把每一根的一端磨尖，把另一端弯过来，这样我们就可以把找到的每一块小木头固定在海床上。
Oh my God.
我的天啊。
So at the end we have, like a butterfly on a piece of cardboard all pinned down, we have thousands of sharpened bicycle spokes driven through every wood fragment all the wreck, holding it down while we map it.
所以最后我们有了一个像固定在纸板上的蝴蝶一样的东西，我们有成千上万根磨尖的自行车辐条穿过残骸中的每一块木片，在测绘时把它固定住。
This bicycle spoke thing became standard practice, although now they have higher tech ways of doing it. A lot of stuff George and Fred figured out along the way became standard.
这个自行车辐条的方法成了标准做法，尽管现在他们有了更高科技的方法。乔治和弗雷德在此过程中弄明白的很多东西都成了标准。
Another thing they were the first to do? Reconstruct an entire ship from its fragments on the ocean floor. At that time, nobody knew what Byzantine ships look like. I asked Fred about this.
他们做的另一件第一件事？从海床上的碎片中重建一整艘船。那时，没人知道拜占庭船只长什么样。我问了弗雷德这个问题。
I mean, frankly, even though you've done it, it still seems impossible to me.
我的意思是，坦率地说，尽管你做到了，它对我来说似乎仍然是不可能的。
Well, it almost was impossible. I'm fond of saying, if they had been one less fragment of the ship down there on the seabed, I wouldn't have been able to put the pieces together. There was just barely enough evidence to reconstruct the shape and dimensions of the ship.
嗯，几乎是不可能的。我喜欢说，如果那海床上的碎片少一块，我就无法把这些零件拼在一起。证据太勉强了，足以重建这艘船的形状和尺寸。
And another part of this was that when this ship sank, it came down on bedrock, and then slid further down the slope, and the stern end of the ship came into sand and made an impression of itself into the sand.
而这其中的另一部分是，当这艘船沉没时，它落在了基岩上，然后进一步滑下斜坡，船尾沉入了沙子中，在沙子里留下了自己的印记。
Incredibly that impression, held in place by some wood fragments, stayed intact for nearly 1,400 years. In order to figure out what the hull looked like, Fred had to invent a way to measure the dent in the sand. He built this contraption using a protractor, some string, and a flashbulb. Seriously. Again, that's a technique still used, although in much improved form, today.
令人难以置信的是，那个印记在一些木头碎片的支撑下，保持完整了近1400年。为了弄清楚船体长什么样，弗雷德不得不发明一种测量沙坑的方法。他用量角器、一些绳子和闪光灯泡制造了这个装置。说真的。同样，这种技术即使在今天，尽管形式上改进了很多，仍在使用。
So huge triumph. 1967. Fred's figured it out. He knows what the ship looks like, and he writes it up, understandably proud, as his PhD thesis.
所以巨大的胜利。1967年。弗雷德弄明白了。他知道这艘船长什么样，他写了出来，理所当然地感到自豪，作为他的博士论文。
Except a few years later, a friend sees it, someone who knows more about ships, and says--
除了几年后，一个朋友看到了它，一个更了解船只的人说——
You know, Fred, your ship would never have gotten out of the harbor. It's simply hydrodynamically unsound.
你知道吗，弗雷德，你的船永远出不了港口。从流体力学上讲是不合理的。
Fred's mistake? Although he had the back half of the ship almost perfect-- that's where most of the wood fragments came from-- he had just extended the lines forward to estimate the front of the ship. But since he didn't know anything about ship engineering, he got it wrong.
弗雷德的错误？尽管他把船的后半部分做得几乎完美——那里有大部分木头碎片——但他只是向前延伸了线条来估计船的前部。但因为他什么都不懂船只工程，他弄错了。
Working with a colleague who built scale models, it took Fred 15 more years to get the drawings right and ready for publication. Since Fred's not one to brag, here's George.
与一位制造比例模型的同事合作，弗雷德又花了15年时间才把图纸弄对并准备出版。因为弗雷德不是那种会吹嘘的人，这是乔治说的。
What Fred did did not just allow to see what the ship looked like. It actually revolutionized all of our ideas about ancient ship construction. I mean, it was incredibly important. It wasn't just saying, this is what it looked like. Because he found out that the ship was built in an ancient manner below the waterline and in a modern matter above the waterline. In other words, it's a transitional ship in a transitional period, between the ancient and modern world.
弗雷德所做的不只是让我们看到船长什么样。它实际上彻底改变了我们关于古代造船的所有想法。我的意思是，这非常重要。他发现这艘船在水线以下以古老的方式建造，而在水线以上以现代的方式建造。换句话说，它是古代和现代世界之间过渡时期的一艘过渡性船只。
By the way, this is the George and Fred partnership. Fred does the endless, meticulous scholarship. George is certainly also a scholar, but he's the better diver and the better salesman. George traveled the world talking up Fred's work, spreading the gospel of nautical archaeology, and raising money to keep Fred hunched over tiny fragments of wood and pottery for 50 years.
顺便说一句，这就是乔治和弗雷德的合作关系。弗雷德做无尽、细致的学术研究。乔治当然也是个学者，但他是个更好的潜水员和更好的推销员。乔治走遍世界谈论弗雷德的工作，传播航海考古学的福音，并筹集资金让弗雷德50年来一直埋头于小块木头和陶器碎片。
The partnership worked. By 1982, Fred figured the ship out. As far as he could tell, the wreck was a routine merchant ship. A bit ho-hum, he called it. It was time to move on.
合作成功了。到1982年，弗雷德弄清了这艘船。据他所知，这艘残骸是一艘普通的商船。他称之为乏善可陈。是时候前进了。
He was wrapping things up at the site in Turkey. But just as Rush Hour was followed by Rush Hour 2, just as Lethal Weapon 2 led to Lethal Weapon 3, the Fred and George franchise was not over yet. Right when they thought they'd retire, they got pulled back in for one last caper-- their biggest caper yet.
他在土耳其的遗址完成了工作。但就像《尖峰时刻》（Rush Hour）之后紧接着《尖峰时刻2》，就像《致命武器2》（Lethal Weapon 2）引出《致命武器3》一样，弗雷德和乔治的系列并没有结束。就在他们以为可以退休时，他们又被拉回来执行最后一次任务——他们最大的一次任务。
Fred got surprise news from some of his interns.
弗雷德从他的一些实习生那里得到了令人惊讶的消息。
Oh, Fred, you have to come and see what's been discovered. And I'm taken to this store room where there were some Turkish college student interns in there, cleaning these amphoras. And they were discovering graffiti on them, inscriptions on them.
哦，弗雷德，你得来看看发现了什么。我被带到这个储藏室，那里有一些土耳其大学生实习生在清洗这些双耳瓶。他们发现了上面的涂鸦，铭文。
And you thought there weren't any, right?
你以为没有，对吧？
No. And we had looked for inscriptions on them. But the growth, marine growth on them, had concealed these inscriptions.
没有。我们确实找过上面的铭文。但海洋生长物，上面的海洋生长物，掩盖了这些铭文。
The inscriptions were cryptic. Just some initials in Greek and some symbols. To figure out what they signified, Fred went on what would become his very last dive. He went down and brought up hundreds of amphoras, those jars.
铭文很隐晦。只是一些希腊语的首字母和符号。为了找出它们代表什么，弗雷德进行了他最后一次潜水。他下去捞起了数百个双耳瓶，那些罐子。
And this led to a series of discoveries that changed how scholars understand the Byzantine Empire. For starters, they realize that the amphoras were made in uniform sizes, with uniform-sized mouths and uniform-sized stoppers. This showed that the Byzantines were using sophisticated mass production techniques more than a thousand years before the Industrial Revolution. They were way more advanced than anyone realized. The parts were uniform so that different components could be made all over the empire at different factories.
这导致了一系列改变了学者对拜占庭帝国理解的发现。首先，他们意识到双耳瓶是统一尺寸制造的，口径统一，塞子也统一。这表明拜占庭人在工业革命前一千多年就在使用复杂的批量生产技术。他们比任何人意识到的都要先进得多。零件是统一的，以便不同的组件可以在帝国的各个地方在不同的工厂制造。
And then Fred cracked the inscriptions, which revealed something surprising.
然后弗雷德破解了这些铭文，揭示了一些令人惊讶的事情。
We finally realize from an inscription that the captain of the ship was a priest. And in the seventh century, there were a lot of priest sea captains, because the church owned a lot of ships.
我们最终从铭文中意识到船长是一名牧师。在七世纪，有很多牧师船长，因为教会拥有很多船只。
So it's a ship owned by the Christian church, transporting supplies for the military. What Fred thought was a ho-hum merchant vessel turned out to be the key to understanding that the Byzantine church and the Byzantine army were far more intertwined than anyone knew.
所以这是一艘由基督教教会拥有的船，运送军事补给。弗雷德认为是一艘乏善可陈的商船，竟然是理解拜占庭教会和拜占庭军队比任何人所知更紧密纠缠的关键。
In fact, Fred believes, on the day they ship sank in 626 AD, the church had lent the ship to the military to get supplies to troops who were fighting the Persian empire. It was the final year of one of the longest and most exhausting wars in the ancient world. The church's involvement and those mass production factories were part of this remarkable military supply chain that Fred helped uncover. In part because of that industrial sophistication, the Byzantines, who controlled much of modern day Turkey, Eastern Europe, parts of Italy, all the way to Spain, defeated the Persians, who ruled over present-day Iran and most of the Middle East.
事实上，弗雷德认为，在公元626年那艘船沉没的那天，教会把这艘船借给了军队，以运送补给给正在与波斯帝国作战的部队。那是古代世界最漫长、最令人精疲力竭的战争的最后一年。教会的参与和那些批量生产工厂是弗雷德帮助揭开的那个了不起的军事供应链的一部分。部分由于那种工业复杂性，控制了现代土耳其、东欧、意大利部分地区一直到西班牙的拜占庭人，击败了统治着现在的伊朗和中东大部分地区的波斯人。
And at the very moment Yassiada sank, Muhammad was forming the armies that would, a few years later, lead to the Muslim takeover of much of the weakened Persians' territory. Then those Muslim armies started fighting the Byzantines, Christians, in wars that would continue for centuries, and of course feel pretty relevant today.
就在亚西岛沉没的那一刻，穆罕默德正在组建军队，这些军队几年后将导致穆斯林占领大部分衰弱的波斯人的领土。然后那些穆斯林军队开始与拜占庭人、基督徒作战，这些战争将持续几个世纪，当然在今天看来非常有意义。
By the time he was done, Fred had figured out not just what the ship looked like, and who owned it, and what it carried, and what it was doing the day it sank, but how that ship fit into the global politics of the day.
当他做完时，弗雷德不仅弄清了这艘船长什么样，谁拥有它，它运送什么，它在沉没那天在做什么，还弄清了那艘船如何适应当时的全球政治。
That's right.
那是正确的。
And that took 50 years.
那花了50年。
Well, I guess, yeah. That's right. That's pretty depressing. I mean, I will spend some time today working on finishing, solving that puzzle.
嗯，我想，是的。没错。这太令人沮丧了。我的意思是，我今天会花些时间完成、解决那个谜题。
You're working on Yassiada today, 50 years later.
你今天还在研究亚西岛，50年后。
Yes. Every day I spend a little time on that project.
是的。每天我都会在这个项目上花点时间。
The interview was over. I left the studio. And then Fred turned to George while the tape was still rolling.
采访结束了。我离开了工作室。然后弗雷德转过身对乔治说，当录音带还在转动时。
Didn't seem like 50 years, anyway.
无论如何，看起来不像50年。
Adam Davidson is part of the Planet Money team at www.npr.org/money.
亚当·戴维森是www.npr.org/money上“金钱星球”团队的一员。
Act Three. The Answer to the Riddle is Me.
第三幕。谜题的答案是我。
We close our show today with this true story from David MacLean.
今天我们以大卫·麦克林（David MacLean）的这个真实故事结束我们的节目。
On October 13, 2002, I woke up in a train station in Secunderabad, India with no passport and no idea who I was or why I was in India.
2002年10月13日，我在印度塞康德拉巴德（Secunderabad）的一个火车站醒来，没有护照，不知道我是谁，也不知道我为什么在印度。
I lost my memory. I lost it along with Fred Flintstone, Marge Simpson, Jack Bauer's wife in the first season of 24, Saleem Sinai in the late middle sections of Midnight's Children, Guy Pearce in Memento, Geena Davis in A Long Kiss Goodnight, Jason Bourne, and scores of sitcom characters who were bonked on the head, only to regain everything with another sizeable bonk.
我失去了记忆。我和摩登原始人弗雷德、玛吉·辛普森、第一季《24小时》里的杰克·鲍尔的妻子、《午夜之子》中后期的萨利姆·西奈、《记忆碎片》里的盖·皮尔斯、长吻之夜里的吉娜·戴维斯、杰森·伯恩以及众多被敲了脑袋后又靠另一次重击恢复记忆的情景喜剧角色一起失去了记忆。
I went to India as a Fulbright scholar. I worked out of university of Hyderabad. I had a small rooftop flat right next to the elevator engine. At first I thought it was a hell of a score, but these apartments are all over the city, and they're illegal, not included in the original building plan. It was incredibly hot, and the elevator engine squeaked and screamed as it lugged people up and down the building. But I did have the entire roof to myself, and could sit out there and watch kids all over the neighborhood flying kites from other rooftops.
我作为富布赖特学者来到印度。我在海得拉巴大学工作。我在电梯机房隔壁有一个小小的顶楼公寓。起初我以为这是一个绝佳的收获，但这些公寓遍布全城，而且是非法的，不包括在原始建筑规划中。天气热得要命，电梯机房在搬运人们上下楼时吱吱作响，尖叫不断。但我确实拥有整个屋顶，可以坐在那里看着邻里的孩子们在其他屋顶放风筝。
I was settling down to do my work. I became a member of a library. It had a friend named Veda, a local grad student, and we had dinner together nearly every night. I was taking my anti-malarial drug, Lariam, every Thursday, just like my doctors told me.
我定下来开始工作。我成了图书馆的会员。有一个叫韦达（Veda）的朋友，是当地的研究生，我们几乎每天晚上一起吃饭。我每周四服用我的抗疟疾药物拉里亚姆（Lariam），就像医生告诉我的一样。
One weekend in early October, I got really sick. Veda brought a doctor over to my flat. The doctor took my temperature, my blood pressure, palpated my stomach, gave me three injections. I asked the doctor what was in the injections, and he said, "medicine." I spent the next two days thrashing in my damp bed in fever dreams.
十月初的一个周末，我病得很重。韦达带了一位医生到我的公寓。医生量了我的体温、血压，摸了我的肚子，打了三针。我问医生针里是什么，他说：“药”。接下来的两天我都在潮湿的床上做着发烧的噩梦。
Veda called me in the morning of October 12. He had nicknamed me hero. "Hello, Hero. Are you up for some dinner or something?" I had no idea who he was. He spent the next five minutes trying to draw my memory, but as far as I knew, he was a stranger. I explained to him that he had the wrong number, and then hung up.
韦达在10月12日早上给我打了电话。他给我起了个绰号叫“英雄”。“你好，英雄。想吃晚餐之类的吗？”我不知道他是谁。他花了五分钟试图唤起我的记忆，但就我所知，他是个陌生人。我向他解释他打错了电话，然后挂断了。
On October 13, 2002, I woke up in a train station in Secunderabad with no passport and no idea who I was. When I say that I woke up, I don't mean I was on a bench passed out and woozily came to. I mean all of a sudden, I was aware of my surroundings.
2002年10月13日，我在塞康德拉巴德的一个火车站醒来，没有护照，不知道我是谁。当我说我醒来时，我不是说我在长椅上昏迷然后恍惚地清醒过来。我是说突然之间，我意识到了周围的环境。
I was standing on the train platform staring at a monitor. People were pushing past me. Train announcements in another language were coming out of static-filled speakers. There were crowds of women in burkas standing near a stall where a man was making omelets. Massive trains would sound their massive horns before they trundled out of the station. And I suddenly was in the midst of all of this.
我站在站台上盯着监控屏幕。人们推搡着我。另一种语言的列车广播从充满静电的扬声器里传出来。穿罩袍的女人们成群结队地站在一个摊位附近，那里的男人正在做煎蛋卷。巨大的火车在驶出车站前会发出巨大的喇叭声。我突然置身于这一切之中。
At that moment, staring at the monitors, I was a blank sheet that had just been rolled in the typewriter. No backstory, no motivation, no distinguishing characteristics, no real idea what I even looked like.
那一刻，盯着屏幕，我是一张刚刚被卷入打字机的空白纸。没有背景故事，没有动机，没有显著特征，甚至不知道自己长什么样。
A man came up to me. He was wearing a uniform. He had a peaked cap and carried a long stick. He wanted to know if anything was wrong. I panned down from the monitor to his face. He was a little older than I was, but not much. His moustache was new and seemed uncertain if it would stay. Mostly, though, his face was kind.
一个人向我走来。他穿着制服。他戴着尖顶帽，拿着一根长棍。他想知道是不是出什么事了。我从屏幕向下看向他的脸。他比我大一点，但没大多少。他的胡子是新的，似乎不确定它是否会留下来。不过，他的脸大部分很和善。
I said to him, I have no idea who I am. Some chamber of emotion was unlocked in me and I started to cry. Blubber, really.
我对他说，我不知道我是谁。我内心深处的某个情感空间被解锁了，我开始哭泣。呜咽，真的。
The policeman pulled a little away from me. He spent a moment considering his strategy, and finally decided on "There, there. Please calm down. I'm used to this situation. You foreigners come here to my country and do your drugs. I've seen this before many times." He pointed to a patch on his shoulder. "I'm here for you. I'm a tourist officer. Now, do you have a passport?"
警察稍微离我远了一点。他花了一会儿考虑他的策略，最后决定说：“行了，行了。请冷静。这种事我见多了。你们这些外国人来到我的国家，吸你们的毒。我见过很多次了。”他指了指肩膀上的臂章。“我为你而来。我是旅游警察。现在，你有护照吗？”
I shook my sobbing head. "I think I slept in a room with monkeys last night."
我抽泣着摇了摇头。“我想我昨晚和猴子睡在一个房间里。”
"OK. Now do you have in your possession a wallet?"
“好吧。现在你有钱包吗？”
I reached to my back pocket and pulled out a leather wallet stamped with an image of a cowboy with guns drawn. I was delirious with happiness. I open the wallet and there was my New Mexico driver's license. "That's me!" I shrieked as I shoved my finger on the square inch picture.
我伸手摸向后口袋，掏出一个压着牛仔拔枪图案的皮夹。我因为幸福而语无伦次。我打开钱包，里面有我的新墨西哥州驾照。“那是我！”我尖叫着，把手指按在那个一平方英寸的照片上。
The officer took my wallet and put it in his pocket. "OK," he said. "Let's get you somewhere else."
警察拿过我的钱包放进口袋。“好吧，”他说。“让我们带你去别的地方。”
I don't remember what happened next. My memory of that day and the next is a string of Christmas lights where only a few are lit. There's no sense to be made of which lights are lit, and you can flick at the dead bulbs as long as you want. They're not coming back on.
我不记得接下来发生了什么。我对那天和接下来一天的记忆就像一串只亮了几盏灯的圣诞彩灯。搞不清楚哪盏灯亮着，无论你怎样拨动那些坏掉的灯泡，它们都不会再亮了。
The officer told me his name was Rajesh, but I could call him Josh. He explained that it would be easier for me, since I was an American, to call him that. I thanked him.
警察告诉我他的名字是拉杰什（Rajesh），但我可以叫他乔什（Josh）。他解释说这对我来说更容易，因为我是美国人，可以那样叫他。我感谢了他。
We went through my wallet and found an internet cafe membership card. We went into a cafe that had the same logo. We got into my Hotmail account. By what means I was able to remember my internet address and password, I can't answer. All I know is that I send an email to my parents that contained the following information.
我们翻了我的钱包，找到了一张网吧会员卡。我们走进了一家有同样标志的咖啡馆。我们登录了我的Hotmail帐户。我凭什么记得我的互联网地址和密码，我无法回答。我只知道我给父母发了一封电子邮件，包含以下信息。
One. I was sorry for being a drug addict and for being such a terrible son.
一。我很抱歉作为一个吸毒者，很抱歉作为一个如此糟糕的儿子。
Two. I was in trouble, but I should be OK soon, since the police were helping me.
二。我遇到麻烦了，但我应该很快就会好起来，因为警察在帮我。
Three. I would be home soon, and would work really hard to be a better person and earn their respect back.
三。我很快就会回家，我会努力成为一个更好的人，赢回他们的尊重。
Josh took me to a guesthouse which the police use as a safehouse for troubled foreigners. A Chinese woman ran the place, and she was known for being good with lost sheep tourists. The three of us sat down in our living room. White marble tile, creaking wooden furniture, and a shrine in the corner with a young man's picture on it. She gave me a glass of flat Sprite and she told me her story.
乔什带我去了警察用作外国问题人士安全屋的一家旅馆。一位中国妇女经营这个地方，她以善于照顾迷途游客而闻名。我们三个人坐在客厅里。白色大理石瓷砖，吱吱作响的木制家具，角落里有一个年轻男人照片的神龛。她给了我一杯不带气的雪碧，并告诉我她的故事。
Her son had been traveling in Singapore when some bad men had injected him with drugs. He overdosed. She never got to see his body. They sent his ashes to her in a cardboard box. She wept as she told me this. "You do not understand what you are doing to your mother when you put these drugs into your body." She grabbed my hands and squeezed hard. I cried right back at her.
她的儿子在新加坡旅行时，被坏人注射了毒品。他服药过量死了。她没能看到他的尸体。他们把他的骨灰装在一个纸箱里寄给她。她讲述时泪流满面。“你根本不知道当你把这些毒品放进身体时，你在对你的母亲做什么。”她抓住我的手，用力挤压。我对着她也哭了。
I was a drug addict, and I was breaking my mother's heart. I swallowed the narratives that they had given me. My brain was empty and famished. I'd taken anything.
我是一个吸毒者，我正在撕碎我母亲的心。我吞下了他们给我的叙述。我的大脑空空如也，饥渴难耐。我什么都接受。
Josh, the woman and I sat down and tried to remember my parents' phone number, which hasn't changed since 1977. It took six hours for me to remember the first phone number I'd never learned. The woman dialed and handed me the phone when it was ringing. My mother answered. I started crying at the sound of her voice. I recognized it. I couldn't picture her, but that voice I knew. "I'm so sorry, mom. I didn't mean to do this to you."
乔什、那位妇女和我坐下来试图记住我父母的电话号码，那个号码自1977年以来就没变过。我花了六个小时才记起我从未学过的第一个电话号码。妇女拨通了电话，在电话铃响时递给了我。我妈妈接听了。听到她的声音我开始哭泣。我认出了它。我无法想象她的样子，但我知道那个声音。“我很抱歉，妈妈。我不是故意要这样对你的。”
"David, you didn't do anything. We got your email. Are you safe?"
“大卫，你什么都没做。我们收到了你的邮件。你安全吗？”
"I'm in a guesthouse. Josh and this woman are helping me. I don't have my passport, but I'm going to get to Delhi and come home. Can I come home?"
“我在一家旅馆。乔什和这个妇女在帮我。我没有护照，但我会去德里然后回家。我可以回家吗？”
"Of course you can come home. You said there's a woman helping you? Let me talk to her."
“当然你可以回家。你说有一个妇女在帮你？让我和她谈谈。”
"I'm so sorry I've been out of touch for so long. I've been a terrible person, an awful son."
“我很抱歉我这么久没联系。我一直是一个糟糕的人，一个可怕的儿子。”
"David, we talked last Tuesday. What's the woman's name?"
“大卫，我们上周才谈过。那个妇女叫什么名字？”
"She wants to know your name."
“她想知道你的名字。”
"Mrs. Lee," the woman said. "Is that your mother? Let me speak with her."
“李太太，”妇女说。“那是你母亲吗？让我和她谈谈。”
Mom worked at a software company in Marion, Ohio, and one of her coworkers was married to a woman from Hyderabad. Mom told Mrs. Lee that she was going to get the phone number for this coworker's family and have them come over to help.
妈妈在俄亥俄州马里昂的一家软件公司工作，她的一个同事嫁给了海得拉巴的一个女人。妈妈告诉李太太，她要拿到这个同事家人的电话号码，让他们过来帮忙。
I was put to bed before the sun set. I didn't sleep. The room begin to twist. It didn't behave. One corner of the ceiling would be too close. Another would be miles away. The blankets itched. I was afraid to drink the Sprite. Birds flew onto the balcony and looked at me dismissively.
我在日落前被送上床。我没睡。房间开始扭曲。它不听使唤。天花板的一个角落太近了。另一个角落则在几英里之外。毯子很痒。我害怕喝雪碧。鸟儿飞到阳台上，轻蔑地看着我。
I knew suddenly that if I left the room, I would walk into a wide, pink kitchen, and there were crackers on the cupboard, and if I went into that kitchen and pulled the crackers down from the cupboard and said something, said something specific, a sentence, something that was totally, feignlessly me, then I'd be all right.
我突然知道，如果我离开这个房间，我会走进一个宽敞的粉色厨房，碗柜里有饼干，如果我走进那个厨房，把饼干从碗柜上拿下来，然后说些什么，说些具体的，一个句子，一些完全、毫无虚假的我，那么我就没问题了。
I knew that as soon as I said it, all of my loved ones would flood up from the basement and the other rooms where they'd been hiding. They would grab me and celebrate me and hold me in their arms.
我知道一旦我说了，我所有的亲人都会从地下室和其他他们躲藏的房间里涌出来。他们会抓住我，庆祝我，拥抱我。
I stood at the door of the small room in this guesthouse in Secunderabad and was ready to enter into the arms of all of those people who loved me and knew me. I just needed to remember what I was supposed to say. It was right on the tip of my tongue.
我站在塞康德拉巴德这家旅馆小房间的门口，准备走进所有爱我、认识我的人的怀抱。我只需要记住我该说什么。它就在我的舌尖上。
I stood at the doorway for over an hour trying to remember. I would open the door a crack and peer out, looking for where all my loved ones were hidden, then bang the door closed. I did this enough times for Mrs. Lee to get freaked out and call my mom's coworker's family.
我站在门口一个多小时试图回忆。我会把门打开一条缝，窥视外面，寻找我所有亲人藏在哪里，然后砰地关上门。我做了足够多次，让李太太感到害怕，并打电话给妈妈同事的家人。
I lay back down and tried to remember. The room was getting worse. There were voices. I flipped the mattress over to find where they were coming from. They alternated between giving me hints as to the phrase I was supposed to say and mocking me for not knowing it already. "Isn't that just like you?" they'd scold.
我躺回床上，试图回忆。房间变得越来越糟。有声音。我翻转床垫寻找它们来自哪里。它们交替着给我提示我该说的短语，并嘲笑我还没记起来。“那不是就像你吗？”它们责骂道。
I was sweating. I'd wet myself. Two men walked into my room. I'd never seen them before. They were both in their early 60s. One man had a silver beard and a Pompadour. The other had a thick mustache and jet black hair and an overgrown Beatles mop top. They both had dark South Indian complexions.
我出汗了。我尿床了。两个男人走进我的房间。我以前从没见过他们。他们都六十出头。一个男人有银色的胡子和蓬巴杜发型。另一个留着浓密的胡子，留着乌黑的头发和过长的披头士式拖把发型。他们都有南印度人的深色肤色。
"I'm Mr. Desappa and this is Mr. Sampson. Your mother summoned us here to help you."
“我是德萨帕（Desappa）先生，这位是桑普森（Sampson）先生。你母亲传唤我们来帮你。”
I looked at the two men looming over me. "This isn't going well at all," I said.
我看着笼罩着我的两个男人。“这进展得一点也不顺利，”我说。
Sampson helped me up while Desappa flipped the mattress back over. They laid me down and knelt on the floor beside me. "You'll be OK. Jesus loves you." They began to pray.
桑普森帮我起来，同时德萨帕把床垫翻了回去。他们让我躺下，在旁边的地板上跪下。“你会没事的。耶稣爱你。”他们开始祈祷。
The men stayed all night, praying and laying their hands on me as they prayed. I'm not sure when they called the ambulance.
男人们待了一整晚，祈祷并把手放在我身上。我不确定他们什么时候叫的救护车。
The next day I came to again. Bruises on my wrists from the restraints. I was in the mental institution, Greenlands Mental Facility. Dirty walls, small table, glass of water, drawn cloth curtain.
第二天我再次清醒。手腕上有约束带造成的淤青。我在精神病院，格陵兰心理设施。脏兮兮的墙，小桌子，一杯水，拉上的布帘。
A doctor with a receding hair line sat at the edge of my bed making notes in a file with a pen that wasn't cooperating. He kept scribbling in the margins to get the ink to flow.
一位发际线后移的医生坐在我的床边，用一支不配合的笔在文件夹里记笔记。他一直在空白处乱涂乱画，试图让墨水流出来。
The doctors put me on Haloperidol, an anti-psychotic, so my hallucinations slowed, and I quieted enough to be unstrapped. I was doped up on enough Valium that I was able to have visitors.
医生给我用了氟哌啶醇，一种抗精神病药，所以我的幻觉减少了，我安静下来，足够被松开约束带。我服用安定到了我能接待访客的地步。
Veda rounded up every American he knew, figuring I'd be more comfortable surrounded by them. These visitors acted like they knew me. They called me Dave, so I played along. They brought me newspapers and cigarettes. I had never smoked a day in my life, but I started chain smoking in the mental institution.
韦达找来了他认识的每一个美国人，觉得我被他们包围会更舒服。这些访客表现得好像认识我一样。他们叫我戴夫，我就随大流。他们给我带来报纸和香烟。我这辈子从没抽过烟，但我开始在精神病院抽烟上瘾。
The the only thing I would consume other than cigarettes was curd rice. The nurses brought it to me in heaping platefuls. The Valium and Haloperidol made me affable. The nurses claimed I was the most entertaining psychotic they'd ever had.
除了香烟，我唯一会摄入的东西是凝乳米饭。护士给我端来满满的一盘。安定和氟哌啶醇让我变得和蔼可亲。护士声称我是她们见过的最有趣的精神病人。
At this point, you know more about me than I did at that moment. Those days where I was fed heavy meds through an IV, people treated me a certain way, and I became the kind of person who is treated like that. All I had to go on for my identity was the reactions of the people around me. I assembled a working self out of the behavior of others.
在这一点上，你知道的关于我比在那一刻我知道的还要多。那些我通过静脉注射重药的日子，人们以某种方式对待我，我就变成了那种被这样对待的人。对于我的身份，我所能依靠的只有周围人的反应。我从他人的行为中组装了一个工作的自我。
The truth, or at least what my family, the State Department, the Fulbright Organization, and I have determined as the truth is that the psychotic break, the hallucinations, the amnesia-- it all was an extreme side effect of the Larium, the anti-malarial drug that was a prescription of choice in those days. It's got a reputation for doing things like what happened to me, as well as much worse.
真相，或者至少是我的家人、国务院、富布赖特组织和我确定的真相是，精神崩溃、幻觉、失忆——这一切都是拉里亚姆的一种极端副作用，那是那个时代人们选择的抗疟疾药物。它有导致发生在我身上的事情以及更糟的事情的名声。
I started taking the drug a month before leaving, as prescribed. My mother says that she could tell I wasn't acting normally before I left, but she chalked it up to the stress of preparing for a year in India
我在出发前一个月开始按照处方服用这种药。我母亲说，她在出发前就能看出我不正常，但她把它归因于准备在印度生活一年的压力。
When my parents walked into my room in the asylum, a motor spun inside my brain. I recognized them, and through them, I recognized myself. I wasn't sure of the details of my life, but my parents defined the broad particulars. We hugged, the three of us making a tent over the bed with our bodies.
当我的父母走进我在精神病院的房间时，我的大脑里有一个马达旋转起来。我认出了他们，通过他们，我认出了我自己。我不确定我生活的细节，但我的父母定义了广泛的细节。我们拥抱在一起，三个人用身体在床上做了一个帐篷。
I told my mom that I was sorry. She told me that she was sorry. My dad pushed his glasses up and rubbed his eyes. My sister Betsy had put together a box for me. In it were two dozen cookies and an array of pictures of me from different times of my life. Me in a kilt, me at the beach, me with a dog, me standing on a station wagon smoking a cigar, me with my sisters, me with my arms around different women. Whoever I was, I couldn't keep a straight face for a photograph.
我告诉妈妈我很抱歉。她告诉我她很抱歉。爸爸推了推眼镜，揉了揉眼睛。我姐姐贝琪给我准备了一个盒子。里面有两打饼干和一系列我一生中不同时期的照片。穿着苏格兰短裙的我，在海滩上的我，带着狗的我，站在旅行车上抽雪茄的我，和姐妹们在一起的我，搂着不同女人的我。无论我是谁，我都无法在照片前保持严肃的脸。
My parents told me where they were saying. They said it was too nice for them, but the restaurant was good and didn't serve them anything too spicy for breakfast. They said I needed to stay for another night at Greenlands, and then I'd go home with them to their hotel, and then we'd get on a plane for the U.S. They said that Sally was excited to see me and that Ann was planning on coming to Ohio for a visit.
父母告诉我他们住在哪里。他们说那对他们来说太好了，但餐厅很好，早餐没给他们提供太辛辣的东西。他们说我需要在格陵兰多待一晚，然后我会和他们一起去他们的酒店，然后我们会乘飞机去美国。他们说萨莉（Sally）很高兴见到我，安（Ann）计划来俄亥俄州拜访。
These names mean as much to you as they did to me. My parents said them like they were people I knew and loved, so I nodded and said I was excited to see them.
这些名字对你来说和对我来说意义一样大。我父母说得好像他们是我认识和爱的人，所以我点头，说很高兴见到他们。
They checked me out the next day. My dad hailed a rickshaw and the three of us piled into the backseat, me in between the two of them.
他们第二天帮我办了出院。爸爸叫了一辆人力车，我们三个人挤进后座，我在他们俩中间。
In Ohio I met Sally, who was my dog. I talked to Ann, my girlfriend, on the phone. I recognized the dog, but not Ann's voice. We hadn't been dating for very long, and my parents didn't have any pictures of her. I had no idea what she looked like. She seemed nice. She seemed like she cared about me.
在俄亥俄州，我遇到了萨莉，那是我的狗。我在电话里和安谈话，我的女朋友。我认出了狗，但没认出安的声音。我们交往的时间并不长，我父母也没有她的任何照片。我不知道她长什么样。她看起来不错。她看起来很关心我。
Those days spent in my parents' house, I mostly stared at pictures, trying to recapture anything of who I was. I developed a system. I would look at the picture and imagine this character of me. Then I would place this character I had developed into these settings. I would imagine the jokes that were told. I would imagine how the character of me would feel. I was gathering information on this character of me all the time.
那些在父母家里度过的日子，我大多盯着照片看，试图夺回我是谁的任何东西。我开发了一个系统。我会看着照片，想象这个我的角色。然后我会把我开发的这个角色放入这些背景中。我会想象讲过的笑话。我会想象那个我的角色会感觉如何。我一直在收集关于我这个角色的信息。
Ann came out on Halloween weekend, and even when I picked her up at the airport, even when she kissed me, I wasn't sure I had the right woman. We spent the weekend hiking with my parents. We had sex that first night of her visit, and she was still a stranger. I could not remember her or any details of our relationship. It was wiped clear.
安在万圣节周末来了，即使我在机场接她时，即使她吻我时，我也不确定我找对女人了。我们周末和父母一起徒步旅行。她在访问的第一晚我们发生了性关系，而她仍然是个陌生人。我记不起她或我们关系的任何细节。一切都被清除了。
She was in love with me. I tried the memory trick of placing the character of me in a relationship with her, and it didn't fit. I couldn't conceive of myself loving her. Sometimes I think that forgetting her with the cruelest thing I've ever done to a person.
她爱我。我尝试了把我的角色和她建立关系进行记忆的技巧，但这不适合。我无法想象自己爱她。有时候我认为忘记她是做过的对一个人最残忍的事情。
I called her a week later and broke up with her. Ann isn't her real name, by the way. She asked me to change it for this story.
一周后我给她打电话分手了。顺便说一句，安不是她的真实名字。她要求我为了这个故事更改它。
I flew back to India on November 20, a little more than a month after the incident. I wasn't entirely stable yet, but I was terrified that the Fulbright Organization would pull my funding if I gave them too much time to mull my psychological condition. I figured the best way back to health was to act like I was healthy. I put on a placid professional exterior while inside I was a full martini glass placed on a rubber ball.
我在11月20日飞回印度，距离事件发生一个多月。我不完全稳定，但我害怕如果我给他们太多时间去思考我的心理状况，富布赖特组织会撤回我的资金。我想恢复健康的最好方法是表现得像健康一样。我穿上了一个平静的专业外观，而在内心，我是一个放在橡胶球上的满满的马提尼酒杯。
It wasn't until I was on the connecting flight into Hyderabad that I realized I had no idea of where I lived. I panicked as we were touching down. I figured I'd get a cab. I just had no idea where to tell the driver to go.
直到我在前往海得拉巴的转机航班上，我才意识到我不知道自己住在哪儿。我们在着陆时我感到恐慌。我想我会打车。但我不知道告诉司机去哪儿。
Instead, Veda was waiting for me at the airport. I didn't recognize him, but by that time, I recognized the look of someone recognizing me. It was a skill I had developed in Ohio. I'd forgotten that I had emailed him my flight details.
相反，韦达在机场等我。我不认识他，但到那时，我认出了别人认出我的神情。那是我在俄亥俄州开发的一项技能。我忘了我已经用电子邮件把航班细节发给他了。
He clapped me on my back and said, "The hero returns!" He gave me a bag full of toothpaste, ramen, and milk. "Enough to last you for a day," he said.
他拍了拍我的背说，“英雄回来了！”他给了我一袋装满牙膏、拉面和牛奶的东西。“够你用一天的，”他说。
We drove through the city. It was 4 AM and silent. We made turn after turn until we ended up in front of a tall building that looked like all of the other apartment complexes. Veda took me up the elevator and then up a short flight of stairs. He handed me a keyring. "OK then, hero. I will be off. I can get some sleep before the kids start causing terror."
我们开车穿过城市。现在是凌晨4点，静悄悄的。我们转了一圈又一圈，直到我们最终停在一栋看起来和其他公寓大楼一样的高楼前。韦达带我上了电梯，又上了一小段楼梯。他递给我一串钥匙。“那好吧，英雄。我要走了。我能在孩子们开始制造恐怖之前睡一觉。”
"You have kids?" "I will call you on your mobile, and we can go for some dinner at your favorite place."
“你有孩子？”“我会打你的手机，我们可以去你最喜欢的地方吃晚饭。”
I grabbed him, and I learned that Veda didn't like to be hugged.
我抓住了他，我了解到韦达不喜欢被拥抱。
I opened the door. Nothing. The road, the building, and now my apartment. Nothing was jogged, jostled, or loosened in my memory. I was alone, and lonelier than I thought it could be in a room filled with things that I'd selected.
我打开门。什么也没有。路、建筑，现在是我的公寓。在我的记忆中什么都没有被推动、摇动或松动。我是一个人，而且比我想象的在一个充满了自己挑选的东西的房间里要孤独得多。
There were books. I opened them and found my handwriting in the margins. Still nothing. I had read these books. Now I had to read them again. But why bother? If I lost my memory again, all that work would be futile.
有书。我打开它们，发现边上有我的手写笔记。仍然什么都没有。我读过这些书。现在我不得不重新读一遍。但为什么要费心呢？如果我再次失去记忆，所有那些工作都是徒劳的。
The city started to wake up, and the sounds of bicycles, car horns, and newspaper wallahs rose up to me on the roof. I lit up a cigarette to fight the tension building in my chest. If it was going to happen again, I would throw myself off the roof.
城市开始醒来，自行车、汽车喇叭和报童的声音在屋顶升起。我点燃一支烟来对抗胸中积聚的紧张感。如果它再次发生，我会从屋顶跳下去。
I stubbed out the cigarette and opened the door to an apartment furnished with the possessions of a stranger.
我掐灭香烟，打开通往一个布置着陌生人财产的公寓的门。
David MacLean fully recovered all his memory, except for the year proceeding his illness. The story is an excerpt from a book of essays that he's writing about losing his memory and memory loss. He's looking for a publisher.
大卫·麦克林完全恢复了所有记忆，除了生病前的一年。这个故事是他正在写的一本关于失去记忆和记忆丧失的散文集中的选段。他正在寻找出版商。
Our program was produced today by Sarah Koenig with Alex Blumberg, Jane Feltes, Lisa Pollak, Robyn Semian, Alissa Shipp, and Nancy Updike. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder. Production help from Brian Reed. Seth Lind is our production manager, Emily Condon our office manager. Our music consultant is Jessica Hopper.
我们的节目今天由莎拉·柯尼格（Sarah Koenig）制作，亚历克斯·布隆伯格（Alex Blumberg）、简·费尔特斯（Jane Feltes）、丽莎·波拉克（Lisa Pollak）、罗宾·塞米安（Robyn Semian）、艾丽莎·希普（Alissa Shipp）和南希·厄普代克（Nancy Updike）参与。我们的高级制片人是朱莉·斯奈德（Julie Snyder）。布莱恩·里德（Brian Reed）提供了制作帮助。赛斯·林德（Seth Lind）是我们的制作经理，艾米丽·康登（Emily Condon）是我们的办公室经理。我们的音乐顾问是杰西卡·霍珀（Jessica Hopper）。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[致谢]
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International. WBEZ management oversight for our program by our boss, Mr. Torey Malatia. You know, at the WBEZ offices in Chicago, there's a safe within a safe, and inside that, written by hand, some programming ideas Torey has for our show for the year 2111.
《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。我们节目的WBEZ管理监督由我们的老板托里·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia）先生负责。你知道，在芝加哥的WBEZ办公室里，有一个保险箱里的保险箱，里面有托里为我们2111年的节目写的一些节目创意。
I'm dead. Everyone you know is dead. Here's what I'd like you to do.
我死了。你知道的每个人都死了。这是我希望你做的事。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带着《美国生活》的更多故事回来。